quick question from the community they
said what was the goal as far as far as
decision to make gear as a cover-based
shooter and they say I say this because
gears has a very unique gameplay style
that seemed very risky at the time
yeah I mean it was basically uh you know
I love games that fail because you can
see what they try to do and then take it
from there and make it better and that
was you know when Lee Perry showed me
kill switch and I was like yeah there's
something so compelling about the
character like actually interacting with
into the world yeah right and then you
know Perfect Dark came out I think it
was perfect dark zero and you could take
cover in like four spots yeah and I was
like now let's make this like a
universal thing and let's you know let's
combine it with the rolling let's
combining it with everything and the
thing is we had the graphical Advantage
when you have that graphical Advantage
you can take the player's controls and
say hey no here's how are you going to
play now you're not just gonna run
around like an idiot you know you're
actually gonna have to take cover and of
course they all wind up rolling around
like 80 yeah
salute to them all right